we'll take questions for Coach mark
first question here in the front area
newsroom on to see if there's any new
information on clay and Kevon with their
injuries
not really clay said he'll be fine but
you know clay could be half dead and
he'd say he's will see you know he
pulled his hamstring
he thinks it's minor so I don't know
what that means going forward and wound
something with his shoulder and so we'll
see sorry
so I got given all those things apply
what were the keys he thought of the
team ultimately prevailing over those
well you know we I said yesterday and
today that 109 points is plenty to win
the game which is what we had in Game
one but we gave up 118 so is all about
our defense and we held him to 37% and
you know force 15 turnovers and guarded
the 3-point line well so it was
championship defense and that's what
it's gonna take
Nick back left standing Steve Nick free
del ESPN back how would you put into
context the performance DeMarcus gave
you given the fact that he's missed six
weeks and he tore his quad he was great
I mean you know we came in thinking all
right he can you know maybe play 20
minutes and he gave us almost 28 there
was only one time in the game when he
needed a rest which was mid fourth we
gave him a couple minutes and then got
him back in the game but he was
fantastic and you know we needed
everything he gave out there his
rebounding his his toughness his
physical presence you know getting the
ball in the paint and just playing
playing big like he does we needed all
of that so I thought he was fantastic
hey Steve Phil barber Santa Rosa Press
Democrat that 14o run to start the third
quarter we've seen some big third
quarter runs from you guys but how do
you put that one in in context among
the most important you've seen and how
much of that do you think was keyed by
the defensive intensity yeah I mean it
was it was the big point in the game I
thought just staying in the game at at
the end of the second quarter was also
very important I think we were down 12
and a place was going nuts we couldn't
score and Steph and klay both got got
loose and and the game loosened up a
little bit we scored we weren't exactly
making stops but you know we cut the
lead to five and could kind of breathe
at halftime and I think our guys felt
renewed life at that point and came out
and just had a great run to take control
of the game and were able to finish it
out from there it's him in the back
right Steve Tim Reynolds with the AP two
things one you said Steph and klay but
Steph got got loose what was it that was
bothering him early did you ever get any
clarity on that and secondly did you get
did you have a feel at halftime that you
guys were gonna put together one of
those spurts to open a quarter with the
times I mean I couldn't have envisioned
you know forty no but I liked I liked
our position it felt like we should have
been down by a lot more than five and
you know for the first quarter and a
half we had really had a tough time
scoring and so the the last whatever was
four or five six minutes the game
loosened up and and we finally broke
free and started getting some some
buckets we started to look like
ourselves and and so at that point it
just felt better and then you know the
second half we we got it rolling and you
know we ended up with 34 assists which
is you know more like our team and so it
was it was a great win now we got to go
home and and protect our home floor and
we'll see about all the injuries but or
I'm very proud of our team and in
particular all the guys off the bench
Quinn cook hit some huge shots and you
know Bogut came in gave us big
Jerebko as well so it's a hell of an
effort from the bench mark here on the
front left Steve mark Schwartz ESPN
would love to get your impressions of
the final possession where Iguodala hits
the open three first of all the scramble
on Steph the nearly intercepted pass and
the fact that the Raptors allowed a guy
like that to take an open shot and the
fact that he took it with time remaining
on the clock
well I mean you're not gonna let Steph
Curry take the shot
so they double-team Steph and that that
left Andre open and you know he had he
hit another big one earlier in the game
any time Andre can can make a couple
threes it's it's huge for us it loosens
up the game and I thought his play in
the second half was really inspiring at
both ends he did a fantastic job and
he's had a lot of big shots in the
finals before so he was unfazed Tim Jim
Comey athletic Steve you moved clay onto
the Kauai defensive assignment for kind
of freeing up Andre maybe off the ball
do you think that had a difference and
what was the thinking behind that she
just wanted to change the look you know
both teams have a lot of versatility
defensively and both teams have been
kind of switching matchups and changing
the look and we felt that halftime like
it made some sense so we we went with it
and whether that was it or or not I mean
we just got into a good groove
defensively to start that third quarter
and you know so we'll take a look at the
at the tape and assess you know what we
what we see but I was a you know a great
third quarter effort held him to 21
points in that quarter that great to
coach Dan Devine from the ringer
you mentioned needing everything that
DeMarcus was able to give you tonight if
you come out of this game with some
questions about clay and with about
Kevon are you going to need more from
him moving forward do you feel
comfortable with his you know sort of
his health physicality to be able to get
more from him moving forward in the
series from from DeMarcus from DeMarcus
yeah he feels good
in there right now and you know we have
a couple couple days before game 3 so we
do feel confident that we can continue
to get good minutes from him and we're
gonna need them obviously with with all
these injuries in the back Stevie and
Killian with the San Francisco Chronicle
just to go back to Steph for a second
there were reports that he left the game
in the first quarter and that he was
battling some kind of an illness he'd
fill us in on that I think he may have
been a little dehydrated
and that was the word I got he just was
feeling a little bit lightheaded and
went back into the training room and
came back and and was doing much better
so I'm not exactly sure beyond that so
that's all I've got for you last two
quick ones on this side right here Steve
Dan lucky with the Los Angeles Times
can you just kind of expound on sort of
the totality of the team during that run
you mentioned Bogut but like Cooke and
Livingston it seemed like you got
something McKinney from every one of
those guys in the third quarter and how
important is that going to be moving
forwards if you guys are as depleted as
you leave the game well that's what it
takes you know you need your bench no
matter what but in particular when
you've got a lot of injuries so we'll
just continue to go to those guys and
trust them and and they've proven that
they can they can really help us you
know Bogut hadn't played in first game
and three quarters so what he did was
was fantastic out there gave us a little
different look with that lob threat so
we'll just we'll see what we've gotten
and tee it up for game 3 last question
next behind Steve Arash Medina from
Sports Net you mentioned that Andres
unfazed a few years ago so big for you
in the finals what is it about him on
this stage in these big games and the
big moments where he delivers he's just
got a lot of experience he's done
everything in his career he's been in
the Olympics he's won three rings he's
been an all-star
he knows how to play one of the smartest
players I've ever been around
and I think he sensed that that we
needed his production in that second
half and and he came alive thanks Thank
You coach